[Music]
I didn't think I would it wasn't
something about a really focused one
it's funny because like a few years back
I was at a friend's house I'm like yeah
I'm gonna get one of these but I was
just joking I didn't believe it and then
cut to you know four years later Here I
am and I was on my way for a Jimmy Choo
shoe party you know and I got a phone
call like you got an Emmy and I was like
what for rip Tiffany Haddish in shock
over her Emmy win for hosting Saturday
Night Live where she famously wore her
repeat white Alexander McQueen dress her
third time's sporting the gown in public
I feel like I should be able to wear
what I want when I want
however many times I won't as long as I
breathe no we're not gonna wear that
dress again we're gonna wear something
different that still makes the statement
that dress is in my suitcase right now I
will never lose red I was thinking about
auctioning address off the charity and
then I was like wait a minute I like
this dress alone it's clear the designer
dress was a hit just like her breakout
role in girls trip straight up you can
at least two inside Tiffany gave et an
update on the film's potential sequel
I'm hoping so you're not afraid for it
you know I just hope they treat us right
that's all I write every day about it in
my journal I think I already have the
script written it's done they just need
to give it to
[Music]
[Applause]